welcome to the future of Life Institute
my name is Gus Docker I'm here with
Nathan lavense and Nathan is a doing
research and development for waymark
which is an and a company that that's
that does AI video generation he's also
the co-host of the cognitive Revolution
podcast Nathan welcome to the podcast
great to be back
fantastic okay I think we should talk
about uh economic transformation coming
from from AI as we see it today
so if we talk about uh large language
models or a generative AI in general how
do you see those AIS transforming the uh
the economy that's of course a huge
question but perhaps you could you could
tell us about how you think of this
question in in general for sure it is a
huge question I have uh you know limited
confidence
on how the Dynamics will play out I do
think it's you know very hard to predict
we talked last time about agents
um with the emergence of Agents you know
and the the Dynamics that may develop
between them like I have a lot of
uncertainty about how things will shape
up but I think for starters
the smartest thinking that I came to and
and I think the the smartest thinking
I've read from others points to
the unit of a task
as being
the the way to think about things
because
language models are really good at tasks
and also language models at least in
isolation are kind of limited to
discrete or kind of finite tasks because
of their nature with the limited context
window and you know all the things that
folks I think will be familiar with do
you think it's it's so simple that we
can simply describe jobs as being made
up of a number of discrete tasks or is
there something we're missing if we if
we do what what economists sometimes do
and and you know take a job and then
split it into 100 different tasks uh do
you think the kind of straightforward
model there is the right model I think
it's a pretty good start for sure people
always have these kind of binaries like
is it going to augment humans or is it
going to replace humans you know I think
that is
inevitably those things end up being
kind of a false binary and the answer
almost always when I hear something like
that it ends up being in my mind it's
going to be both at the same time and
there it's not that hard to generate
examples of of each different you know
process playing out
uh the examples don't invalidate each
other rather I think they should lead
you to a conclusion that like both of
these things are going to happen and in
different domains you know different
changes May predominate so
I do think that yes like decomposing a
job into tasks and saying which of those
tasks could a language model do
is like a pretty good way to get started
on analyzing what's going to happen and
you know the language models can do big
enough tasks that even if you stop there
I think you have to
I don't know how you could come to any
other conclusion other than they can do
a lot of tasks
so
I've you know started talking about this
in terms of like the unbundling of jobs
into tasks
and
because it is at the same time it does
remain true that if you were to go look
at any given job
and say could a language model do this
whole job
as currently constructed then the answer
is like almost universally no you know
there's some element of
physicality you know which is like the
most obvious one right now I think we're
gonna have robots too but that's a
that's a little bit delayed relative to
gbd4 anyway there's you know sometimes
just a lot of implicit context or there
may be kind of long-term memory
requirements so there are a lot of
things if you just said Can a language
model in isolation you know as it exists
today do this whole job there's a lot of
reasons that the answer kind of boils
down to no but if you start to do time
slicing or you know look at these you
know the tasks that ultimately make up
the job
a lot of times the answer you know for
individual tasks become yes and I think
critically a lot of times
the core task
for the core task it is yes some of the
stuff we do on computers right like we
want to go
I need to go put some uh summary of a
call into my CRM
if I have the transcript of the call and
I want the summary gpd4 can do that
where it is going to get tripped up more
often is like actually logging into the
CRM you know having access to the CRM uh
you know if you are I've used this
example before but if you work at a
doctor's office let's say it's a you
know small office and maybe you have a
mix of responsibilities you know that
may include handling paperwork as the
patient arrives it may include taking
the phone calls and scheduling the
appointments it may include getting you
know height weight and vitals when they
get to the office may include some
interfacing with billing after the fact
you know Alex model right now is not
going to take somebody's blood pressure
so
can do the whole job no but could it
take the call and schedule the
appointment like yes almost for sure
with a little bit of affordance around
access to the scheduling system and you
know maybe uh uh you know synthetic
voice that it can speak in over the
phone to you but otherwise like yeah for
sure it's gonna be able to do that
probably already can so that's that's a
question about whether these models can
do the the core tasks in many Industries
so I could imagine that being true for a
doctor for example where we we could say
that the core task is diagnosing a
patient so you present with a list of
symptoms and from that I've seen very
impressive examples of gpt4 generating a
diagnosis same same goes for drafting
legal documents those are two uh huge
parts of the economy so the medicine and
law and so on uh we could we could talk
about Consulting with uh summarizing and
presenting information in specific ways
but is there perhaps
are there legal protections around
certain industries such that what the
service that the lawyer provides in some
sense is access to his insurance the the
the service that the doctor provides is
access to perhaps some some health
insurance or you know the the the stamp
that says that that this is approved by
a doctor are there legal modes around
industries that will prevent
um AIS from from doing the core tasks
even though they might be capable I
don't know
um there certainly are legal modes
will they prove resilient
to you know the what I expect to be the
sort of incredible demand for direct
access
I would kind of guess that the answer is
no uh but there we may be headed for all
sorts of interesting Dynamics in terms
of
start with medicine for example I've
honestly been very impressed and
pleasantly surprised by how Forward
Thinking some like early adopters seem
to be in like the medical and also the
legal space I would have expected if
you'd ask me just totally operate like
how will people react I would have said
like in a very hostile zero-sum
protection you know oriented sort of way
and it's been less that way I would say
than I expected you see this you know
this book that I keep referencing the AI
revolution in medicine
and they are not shying away from the
fact that gbt4 can do certain core tasks
better than most doctors like they're
they're very clear about that they also
then do pay you know appropriate
attention to the failure modes and like
for now the recommendation is you know
the best care
is going to be from the combination and
you've got all these questions about
like well what is the standard of care
in medicine now is it even okay to not
use an AI in the not too distant future
or would that be violation of the
standard of care then if you do use the
AI like what if it messes up how much is
on you you know what is considered
responsible use we already have this at
least in the US we have this notion of
like
the standard of care is like a
reasonable defense for a doctor like if
you did something and there was a bad
outcome
hey if it was standard of care and
that's what you know a typical good
doctor would have done then like hey you
know things happen it's not your fault
if you deviate from that and you go
freelancing and you know get too
creative and something bad happens and
that is your fault
so that's going to probably get
reconfigured and then you know we've had
the the like Google WebMD you know
debate for the last 15 years of like
doctors don't really always love it when
their patient comes in having like been
on WebMD because they feel like they
already think they know what's what and
maybe they do and maybe they don't and
whatever you know this is going to take
that up a whole other level and
I think it's going to be hard to make
the argument that people shouldn't have
direct access if they don't have other
access you know I mean I can totally see
how like a hospital system or a medical
practice
is not going to be not going to want to
be the ones that provide you direct
access to Ai and say you know have at it
like I don't think I'm going to get that
from my doctor the experience of going
to a doctor likely gets augmented with
you know AI or whatever but they're not
gonna just like give me a chat service
with no supervision because they have
like their own you know
standards to uphold and liabilities and
all that kind of stuff
but I could see
maybe an open AI makes it directly
available to the public I mean it is
today they've got the mitigations in
there around like I'm not a doctor as an
AI language model I can only help you so
much but you can coax still all that
information out of it I just
tell it I'm going to see my doctor
tomorrow
and I want to be as prepared as I can be
for that conversation
that gets me out of any of the concerns
of like I can't help you with this
because now it has this notion going
right we're gonna go see the doctor then
I can help you prepare you know that
seems low stakes so it'll just do it and
then you can have the black if you don't
have that then you'll just have the
black market right because the we talked
about this a little bit last time too
like the stable you know model family is
is out there
it's going to be fine-tuned it's going
to be deployed somewhere you know worst
case scenario it takes a VPN maybe
um but you think about around the world
where I mean Primary Care is scarce
here where I'm in the U.S it's extremely
scarce in a lot of places
I don't see how
it can really be
contained even if it's made illegal in
all honesty so I don't know how that all
shapes up but it doesn't seem like
there's any way to just put a lid on it
you know and and hope everybody kind of
forgets about it I just can't see any
path to that
there seems to be a quite
straightforward story here about how AI
becomes part of of core Industries and
is able to accomplish core tasks we
could imagine a lawyer drafting 30
documents in the time that he would say
it's normally take to to draft one
document on his own
do you expect from this that
productivity worker productivity would
rise and the obvious answer there seems
to be yes right but when we think about
you know if I don't have to send a
letter if I can send an email as opposed
to a letter we might expect worker
productivity to rise if if I can use the
internet
um if I can use smart as smartphone we
might expect that I become more
productive but have people have worker
productivity uh written as much as we
might expect with these previous
Innovations and so yeah do you think do
you think AI will make us more
productive yeah if I had to say a one
word answer I would say yes certainly I
feel that in my day-to-day work you know
software development is undeniably
accelerated by
just the tools we have today whether
that's copilot or I'm using replit more
and more now uh which has some awesome
products as well
how much faster would you say you're
able to program with these AI assistant
tools I think measurement in this area
is really hard in general and it really
varies across subdomain and I think
probably like the productivity
statistics will vary also across
subdomains and even across individuals
and on top of that I think we're gonna
maybe have like a different price regime
that may make like traditional
productivity measurements like kind of
not apply in exactly the same way or
like even GDP may not make a ton of
sense in the not too distant future I'm
expecting a lot of consumer surplus
that's that's one of my like standard
answers here is like
if a
doctor appointment
today costs a hundred dollars and the
gpt4 version costs one dollar
then
GDP could very easily go down even with
like you know a lot more medical you
know advice quality medical advice
perhaps being dispensed so does that
make somebody more productive or you
know I don't know it's like it's all a
little bit weird and you know to answer
your question directly I've seen
examples where it would save me
you know an hour in a second one example
that came to mind was I was just
manipulating some media files
and I wanted to
convert one file type to another file
type
fairly standard operation but I don't
know how to do it and you Google that
stuff it's you know it's Hit or Miss
like you might find exactly what you're
looking for or you might find like
The Hornet's Nest of pain of just like
why aren't these examples working for me
and all I want to do is a stupid simple
thing so you know this is just co-pilot
just typing like comment you know
convert the file to the other file type
boom there's my command right and
those so those are like those hour to to
Second type things where
you know what's that that's a that's a
factor of 3600 right I mean that's an
incredible speed up but then other times
certainly you have these things where
it's like yeah it doesn't really help
that much on this or you know there are
kind of failure modes still where like
the library's been updated since the
training data you know was cut off and
it wasn't very easy to figure that out
you know like why isn't this working it
seems like it should be working oh I see
it's because it's using an old version
that's not the package you know that I
have
so I've definitely seen you know kind of
everything there
but I would say you know other other
things that I've seen just my own
experiences rough number I don't know
twice as fast already and I think that's
that's only you know kind of picking up
especially with like
replied extending this thing this kind
of stuff to
the whole hosting environment you know
the whole kind of file structure you
know being generated right off the bat
again for different individuals right I
mean Ezra client had a great Riff on
this recently I thought it was so smart
where he said if you went back
to pre-internet and you kind of imagined
what the internet might do you could
kind of tell two different stories you
could be like
it's going to give us access to
information like we've never had before
you know it's going to lower all these
barriers you're going to be able to find
answers to any question that you want
online you know you're going to have
instant communication around the globe
with people even like video instant
video conference you would have had to
get on a plane to go see somebody now
you can do this
imagine what's that that's going to do
for productivity oh my God but then the
other story is like
you're going to have this thing that's
going to ping you every five seconds
you're never gonna have any you know
quiet time to yourself there's going to
be infinite you know competing
for your uh Amusement you know all the
time by the way there's also going to be
like tons of just entertaining conflict
that you might you know get sucked into
so how what's that going to do for
productivity and his take which I think
was pretty smart was like in the end it
seems like those almost kind of canceled
each other out for now like we've had
kind of you know roughly consistent
productivity growth we certainly both
feel both of those Dynamics you know
almost all of us do in our own lives
um but you do see the outliers you see
people who are like not bothered by the
distraction or somehow managed to tune
it out and just like crush it and then
you see people who like get totally lost
in the distraction and don't do anything
anymore so
I think AI is going to bring a similar
pack of of kind of pros and cons I'm
John from replet talks about the
Thousand X developer you know there's
like the meme of the 10x developer and
he's like we're entering the era of the
Thousand X developer where the people
that are best at using these tools are
just gonna blow anything that came
before them away
but then the flip side is like if you
can't figure it out or if you get you
know lost in your like you know
dynamically conjured uh metaverse that
you you know are kind of text to 3D
environmenting for yourself as you uh
you know go into like AI dungeon Choose
Your Own Adventure infinite
entertainment then maybe productivity is
not very good at all
I really don't know you know I think
that's going to be just so
so I think it's every everything
everywhere all at once like that that
movie title has proven to be I think
extremely prescient for
AI because it always kind of seems to be
yeah both of those kind of happen
so perhaps we'll see a Divergence of of
people into the ultra productive and the
the almost non-productive uh do you
think do you think we'll see mass
unemployment as a result of of these
tools this is something that whenever
whenever you bring up mass unemployment
thinking about perhaps 25 unemployment
rate
um economists start to to talk about
well we've always had people adapt
people have always been able to find
find different jobs uh would you would
you say that this time it's different
with AI it's different
I do think it's different
I don't know how the current again I
don't know how the current measurements
will ultimately end up looking I've
debated a little bit uh just via email
with Robin Hansen on this and you know
he loves to bet and I was kind of trying
to engage him on that level
and he's you know he's on the bear case
of like
they're not gonna the language model is
not gonna be that big of a deal I'm
obviously convinced they're going to be
a big deal but we still couldn't quite
come to a bed because he was like
focusing on things like Revenue you know
GDP growth and I'm like I just don't
know how GDP is going to respond to some
of these Dynamics
so with employment I think the same
thing is probably true I do think this
time is different I think it's Yuval
Harare who has just a real simple
Paradigm for it kind of oh we talked
about this a little bit last time or
something similar like we used to use
muscles now we have machines to do with
the muscles uh do we don't use our
muscles to survive you know to they're
not like the core of productivity like
they once were
but now it's the brain but now we have
something that can do a lot of the stuff
that their brain can do
seemingly really closing in on the gaps
of you know there are certain things
that we do that it can't but boy that
Gap seems to be shrinking awfully
quickly
where do we go next like we don't have
another organ you know uh that is like
the the third tier of you know and even
with things like emotion or whatever and
that's obviously largely in the brain
and also gbt4 is like
pretty charismatic you know pretty good
conversationalist pretty empathetic
seemingly in a lot of interactions at
least appears to be so I don't know
where
I don't think there's like an obvious
place for people to sort of graduate
into
that said people want to do stuff people
want fulfillment and there's plenty of
activities that are rewarding and like
plenty of those might ultimately be
somewhat economically
you know geared as well I could imagine
a world where it's like
we all have this you know time luxury
and we get to like pursue our you know
passions and interests and make music
and art and all that stuff and
you know that may not count as
employment or you could say maybe it
does count as employment I can also see
like highly bespoke local Services being
kind of a thing like people do these
like murder mystery dinner parties
and you know that's like a
a cool experience that somebody like
really crafts for you know a local
market and
I think there's like a very beautiful
future potentially there that is like if
things go well at all it seems like we
should be in a position where most
people don't have to work to eat
so that's great
um will people choose to like you know
live off a Ubi and just like play piano
all day or or video games more likely or
will they
you know kind of have these like hybrid
things that are sort of like for passion
but also make some money
I really don't know uh but I do think
this time is different I just don't have
I think we're gonna ultimately need new
paradigms new categories probably new
measures you know today it's like you're
employed we've added like underemployed
then we've even got people talking about
like fun employed right
so you're just taking time off and
having some fun and being unemployed I
wouldn't be surprised if there's like
eight gradations of that in the not too
distant future you know where it's like
I sort of work but you know not because
I have to eat but because like why do I
even charge money for this well because
like
people that pay me seem to enjoy it more
you know uh you can imagine a lot of
people well I tried offering this for
free and like my reviews were worse like
just by having a little charge like I
get people that are actually more into
the concept and it's better for everyone
you know that there's some exchange
maybe Associated is that employment I
don't know
yeah so so you mentioned uh we might
move into creating art and music and so
on that seems a little ironic to me
perhaps because we see AI models being
highly capable of creating both both
music and art right now but but the the
the idea of kind of bespoke local
in-person services that seems super
interesting this is this is a a bit uh
in the same frame that I've been
thinking about these these things so for
example we might move to jobs that seem
ridiculous to us now kind of silly
things like come to the park and I'll
teach you how to throw a frisbee in the
right way and this this might constitute
a job this is it is is this but do you
expect us to all be able to uh to be
employed in in that way
I mean not if you know we're still
working on a
you have to work to eat uh basis like
yeah I think there's only so many
frisbee coaches you know and the music
part are the art part
uh you know I
took piano lessons as a kid I'm not very
talented
and
I am in no danger of being paid to play
the piano
but I do still have just enough talent
to enjoy it
and if I had more time
I would you know just a couple years ago
when I did have a little bit more time I
would sit there and play the piano for a
while and it was like I'm not good I'm
never going to be good nobody will ever
pay to listen to me
but it's still fun for me so I think
there is something there you know I look
at chess too and I kind of think
my understanding of Chess you can fact
check me on this but obviously it used
to be only humans that could play chess
then it was like oh now computers have
solved chess then there was a moment of
like actually human
computer teams are the best and now I
believe we've reached the point where
that's no longer true and it's just that
like computers are of a straight best
again
but
people who watch a ton of Chess on the
you know on like
um twitch or whatever you know the
streaming platforms are it's it's bigger
than ever
so I do think that
you know there is some leading
indicators of
value you know at some level this is
like the most obvious thing in the world
and like
you know are certainly our ancestors or
like those that are more enlightened
Among Us would be like how could you
have ever forgotten you know something
so fundamental but like
it does seem like value
as we you know just
intuitively understand it and
economic activity are like significantly
overlapping but not the same thing and
you know we we live in such a capitalist
environment and I'm you know generally
uh one to celebrate the great
achievements of capitalism so don't take
me uh you know as a hater there by any
means but it does seem like
you know we've almost kind of forgotten
that like you can just play the piano
just for you nobody has to pay you and
that can be very rewarding or you can
sit in the park and play chess and you
can get better at it and even if a
computer is better than you then that
can still be like a rewarding way to
spend your time so
I'm optimistic about
people's ability to
find good things to do you know to to
spend their time in ways that are
valuable to them to have like
pleasurable you know experiences and
good relationships and even just growth
you know I think that's a bit too often
conflated with economic activity
I don't think that's inherently economic
and I don't think like
it's necessarily going to be the case
that people are going to get paid for
that stuff
so I don't know I've got a ton of
uncertainty about it what's the uh the
phrase like I'm a utility Optimist but a
revenue pessimist
I think is kind of how I would you know
again in the in the you know sane
scenario where like we don't have a
catastrophic outcome
uh then I think things could be really
really nice even if you're not like
collecting a check have you seen any
interesting Research into how to measure
the utility part there in in new ways so
not thinking in terms of GDP or
employment rate or economic growth in
the traditional sense uh are there any
other numbers we could go to because it
seems like in the end we would like to
to see some numbers we would like to be
able to to make bets I think
um and for that we need something
concrete so have you come across
anything interesting there I mean we we
have something like like the human
development index uh which is kind of
like an an attempt to extend uh GDP into
thinking about health care thinking
about education and so on but even that
seems a little limited perhaps this is a
question that that AIS could solve for
us where we could ask people how much
value they think they're getting from Ai
and then collect data from hundreds of
millions of people yeah I mean there's
also like the which is it uh Bhutan that
has the uh gross happiness index or
national happiness index type of thing I
don't know exactly how they
uh report that but something like that
is definitely interesting Leisure Time
you know would be another thing that I I
would expect to maybe be a leading
indicator like if I think that like
Leisure Time Will lag probably
deployment a little while for now at
least like I'm working harder than ever
I'm obsessed with this stuff and you
know like you could also ask the
question like how much does it work like
when I'm scrolling on Twitter and
reading like academic work nobody's
technically paying me for that and I'm
paid for other things those are kind of
like inputs to the job I don't know it's
all again it all kind of gets blurry
pretty quickly
but if this is going really well
then I do think we should expect to see
something along like the classic you
know Keynes vision of more Leisure less
work and you know then you could also
start to look at metrics which are
tracked like
loneliness you know we've got a
loneliness epidemic you know we should
probably start to see some things like
that reverse I would hope if people have
more time you know then they should
hopefully spend some of that time with
one another and connect in in meaningful
ways
so yeah I think there's probably a I
don't know I don't think there's a great
answer to that but
um let me get started maybe start to
kind of triangulate and piece something
together that would at least be
meaningful
do you think that if we if we succeed in
avoiding catastrophe and we get to this
luxurious situation in which we people
don't have to to work in order to live
do you think we will have lost something
that's that's important to us and here
I'm thinking about the
the the pleasure but also the deeper
sense of meaning that people get from
accomplishing something difficult having
having a job working at a at a goal at a
task for months at a time and then
finally succeeding there's something it
it deeply satisfying about that for for
a lot of people and it might you know my
my go-to example here is is the lawyer
who is gone through law school you know
Blood Sweat and Tears and now comes out
on the other on the other side and sees
that gbt4 is able to pass the bar exam
there's something a bit it's it's more
than annoying it it's it's perhaps a bit
you know a loss of of meaning going on
there
yeah I certainly empathize with that
um I've seen I saw this one Tick Tock
where a doctor is sitting at the
computer and using chat gbt for the
first time and just is go is basically
saying exactly that like
I spent Years Learning this stuff now
this thing just spits it out
you know what the hell
and um you know interestingly on that
Tick Tock too the
the comments we're all women saying well
maybe gbd4 will at least listen to me
when I tell it about my problems
so that's you know you know whatever a
footnote but an important one
so yeah I guess I kind of come back to
the time frame on that it feels like
there is the transition that's one
question to me and then there's kind of
the long term like if you imagine
yourself being born into this regime my
best guess is if you're born into this
regime you basically never have this
problem and you look back on people you
know and kind of think that people were
deluded in the past you know much like
we may look at people who did like human
sacrifice you know like you look at the
Aztec or the Maya you know whatever
human sacrifice and you're like yeah
they were very confused about like how
things work and like what constitutes a
good life and you know so they did all
these things and it seemed right to them
but like it's very clear to us now that
that was wrong
I kind of think that the
ultimately I think it will in retrospect
look mostly like a cope that people told
themselves all these stories about how
like work is Meaningful
and
that doesn't mean that there won't be
meaning right because again like
learn to play the piano and challenge
yourself and it is hard and you know I
personally you know even today with all
of our economic activities swirling
around us like I can find Value in that
so I don't think if you're if you're if
you imagine being born into this regime
and you're like hey I just grew up in an
environment where I never had to work to
eat and so I got to kind of figure out
what you know my definition of meaning
was and you know I don't think we're
gonna have a hard time finding something
that
you know that fills that um job-shaped
hole in our hearts
but
we gotta get there right and that this
intervening period now you're like
you know when the factory leaves town
you know this has been one of the big
Revelations of the last 30 years
economically is like we used to tell a
story where when the factory left town
well everything will just adjust and you
know GDP will grow and you know
something something about if we really
need to we can redistribute but of
course we never really do and so you
know the machinists that used to have
that job at that factory like there is
no other job and there is that loss of
I would all argue status
as much as or more than meaning and
those are maybe conflated obviously
overlapping you know as well
but it's painful to lose status it's
painful to lose income especially if
there is you know we're not yet in a
post scarcity world and your you know
thing that you've invested in and your
status your self-conception your income
is all tied up with an activity and now
like the demand for that activity you
know potentially drops or at least the
rate that you can charge for it drops I
think that's going to be extremely
painful to people and you know
likely to cause a lot of
conflict of All Sorts but I would say I
think it's a generational thing it's
kind of my best guess right now you
think it perhaps uh we could imagine a
world in which we succeed in incurring
death and then we we sing back about all
of the stories we told ourselves about
how death gives lives me if gives
meaning to life and it's it's a
necessary part of a natural process and
so on you think uh the necessity of
having a job could be somewhat in the
same category where we we are out of
kind of because we didn't have a choice
for for hundreds of thousands of years
we we had to work we had to die in a
sense we made up stories that that we
told ourselves that we're comforting But
ultimately not reflective of anything
real that seems right to me I would hate
to think it would be really
you know the flip side of it is just so
unappealing that I can't really count
and it's it you know the idea that like
what we're just gonna be bummed forever
because we have no jobs like all of you
know it's just an inherent thing that we
can never overcome that like nobody
wants to pay me to do anything no I
still get to eat but nobody wants to pay
me to do anything woe is me like I just
my life has no meaning I just don't buy
that it seems like
that's a limited imagination in my view
but perhaps and now we've been talking
about what we could categorize as as
luxury problems if everything goes right
but perhaps this this um this Instinct
for having a job is also an instinct for
staying in control so we we might
imagine that we want to be the ones
making decisions and we are not
interested in handing over all of the
important decision processes to AIS do
you think there's something healthy in
the in that instinct yeah
um
I mean I think it's also to be managed
and you know to be in Balance but yes I
do think
you can be wrong on both sides of that
question I would say again I keep coming
back to this medicine thing because I
just read this whole book and it's you
know it's extremely compelling
and I think we're not too far from a
world where
you probably can get more reliable
medical advice from like gpt4med you
know if we imagine a slightly enhanced
version than you would from
let's say
three quarters of doctors I don't know
90 of doctors I don't see it necessarily
beating the very best doctor just yet
we talked about that last time but in
that scenario if I'm the patient
and I
want the best decision for me then I'm
going to look at the doctor's impulse to
like want to make the decision pretty
skeptically
and say like I want the most likely
right decision and I really don't care
who it comes from and wherever we are in
that chest curve whether it's you know
only the doctor can decide or wait the
computer's better or wait it's the team
or wait it's the computer again
I just want the best for me that's kind
of that
but I do see a lot of pro you know a lot
of benefit also to some sort of you
could call it I guess like precautionary
principle or some just kind of
instinctive you know conservative
impulse to say hey
maybe it's not a great idea for us to
just
you know abdicate all responsibility and
let the systems do everything
um and that's gonna be very hard to
balance I think you know I don't I don't
have a good vision for
what does medicine look like or what is
it what does really anything look like
in a world where individual decisions
are almost always you know a little bit
more likely or maybe significantly more
likely to be right when coming from an
AI but yet you know there's some
threshold potentially or Tipping Point
where
you do that you know to the Max and then
you lose control of everything you know
you just have no idea how those Dynamics
are going to play out agents you know
which is another thing we kind of talked
about last time brings that I think very
much to the fore right in the world as
it exists today if you gave me an agent
that worked well I would be very pleased
and I would happily be like go you know
research uh a new pair of running shoes
for me and give me back three options
and then I would be like go buy the one
you know I don't want to enter my credit
guard and deal with all that stuff if I
can avoid it so great you know if I
could have it Go negotiate my cable bill
on my behalf like that'd be sweet too
you know go pretend you like you're
gonna quit
and you know tell them you're not
renewing another month unless we get a
certain you know price you could
probably get it
but that's before the world starts to
adapt and everybody else has their
agents and the next thing you know my
cable company has its own agent now I've
got agents you know talking to each
other and like everybody into you know
there's some possibility for like a um
a weird equilibrium here where you know
I would hope it's not like I'm not a
game theory you were by any means but I
would hope it's not but it seems like it
could be some sort of nash-like
equilibrium where it's like everybody is
incentivized no matter what strategy
you're playing I'm incentivized to use
my agent and once you're using the agent
I'm still you know I can't defect and
like how do you get out of that it seems
like everybody naturally just kind of
puts more and more stuff on the agents
but yeah again then it's like well what
the hell happens after that we really
don't have any good model of that you
know it's
so yes I'm torn I feel like
I want my agent but I don't want
everybody to all rush to have an agent
at the same time because I have no idea
where that leads and so what do we do I
don't know I think it's very tough you
want someone who has gone through the
annoying process and the time consuming
process of perhaps checking whether
these agents are doing the right thing
and whether they are acting in the way
that you want them to act there are
there are so many tasks for which it it
would be much easier and much much more
pleasant in daily life to Simply
automate them I don't want to call
um the authorities and when I have to do
my taxes as I recently did talk talk to
them for for two hours and then not
really get to solve my problem and so on
there's so many of these types of daily
annoyances that could be solved but I'm
I do fear that if we Outsource all of
these tasks we we begin to lose lose
grasp of reality and not if we're not in
contact with reality we we probably are
going to make worse decisions um this is
this is perhaps a bit analogous to
thinking about
never doing math in in
your head so always Outsourcing all
calculations to a calculator or never
trying to to navigate around in a city
on your own and always looking at at
your smartphone for the map we do
perhaps lose some abilities that we that
we could have had there yeah I mean I
think
a source that has definitely helped
shape my thinking on this is a Jay uh
katra's I hope I'm saying her name quite
right you are she's been a guest on this
podcast and she's she's absolutely
insightful on everything AI her piece on
I believe the title is might paraphrase
slightly but
um absent specific you know intentional
countermeasures the most likely path to
AGI likely leads to AI takeover and
that's basically the story that she's
telling right is one where and Paul
Cristiano just talked about this uh
actually on the bankless uh podcast in
the last few days as well where it's
like
in in their sense of what AI takeover
looks like it's not the sudden out of
the blue you know nobody saw it coming
uh but I think you know they both
articulated in in compelling ways Paul
said uh
you know
in his mind it looks like AI is widely
deployed and then it's kind of like
boy if they really if they were trying
to kill us they definitely could so
let's hope that they really are not and
in the JS version it's kind of like you
know you have this increasingly aiified
economy everything increasingly managed
by AI systems everything kind of working
okay seemingly but like inscrutable and
you know then you sort of lose control
potentially of the system because I mean
nobody can understand the economy today
and that's with people where we at least
have like an intuitive sense of what one
another value and you know how we're
likely to act under like almost all you
know we have a pretty good sense for how
almost everybody's going to act under
almost all circumstances and we have
nothing like that with
and yet you know it's not that hard to
imagine a scenario where the the
delegation to AI has ramped up to such
degree
that
you know it's like that problem of
understanding the economy goes like 100x
more difficult in the AI economy
version so yeah I don't know it is tough
I do think there is definite wisdom to
the notion that like we want to maintain
control I mean I've put as simply as
that like who could argue uh but how do
we not slip down that
that slope of just more and more
delegation until such Point as like
actually we don't really know how this
thing runs anymore I don't know that
definitely seems like the downhill path
you know it definitely seems like the
attractor so I don't know how we avoid
that so we've been alluding to this
notion of catastrophic outcome from from
Ai and this is of course something we at
the future of Life Institute care a lot
about and we are worried about
existential risk from from AI or from
ATI in particular this is something
that's been discussed a lot on this
podcast so we shouldn't go through the
making the case for against specifically
here but I'm interested in what you're
hearing in the AI industry as it looks
now uh how are people reacting to to the
notion that uh
further developments in AI could become
catastrophic it's definitely not a
fringe position anymore that I would say
is you know some form of progress
um I you know the people I talk to
they're all over the map honestly some
are
still pretty Lively unconcerned I'm not
worried you know these things don't have
any in innate desires like they're not
gonna you know why would they do that
uh you know those people could be right
Richard Noe from openai gave the best
answer I've heard to the question why
might this all just go perfectly
smoothly and all this worry was uh was
you know totally misplaced and he said
the best argument for that would be dogs
he said we started with Wolves
and we did stuff that seemed like they
would make the Wolves nicer and like us
more
and gradually over a long time we got
dogs and it basically worked you know
dogs aren't perfect but they're way
better than wolves and you know they're
pretty
you know they're genuinely friendly for
the most part like most of them anyway
so maybe you know that could something
like that could turn out to be right
maybe it's just as all easy
um I don't find that I don't hear
arguments though honestly that are
that are compelling that like it's going
to all be fine and here's why I that
that part always kind of seems to be
missing you know standard of evidence is
like often maybe what people are
debating most where they're like you
know I don't see any reason that would
happen you haven't convinced me that the
bad thing would happen is often like the
position that people end up kind of
taking so kind of debating burden of
proof uh yeah and I mean for me it's
pretty clear that like just the General
survey results you know that we see
where it's like half of people think
there's a 10 half of AI researchers I
think there's a 10 or higher chance of
some catastrophe I don't know how
anybody can really dismiss that at this
point I don't know I don't understand on
what burden of proof Paradigm you would
dismiss that it just doesn't make a lot
of sense to me but you know yet that
position does remain out there you've
got like the
IAC meme space as well I I don't even
know what to make of that I don't think
it's like
generally
even necessarily serious it kind of
seems like a lot of it is somewhat just
like should posting to be honest I think
that the steel man for the effects of
accelerationism is that it's the case of
of nuclear for example where we had uh
potential we had a technology that could
help us solve climate change but we
chose to perhaps over regulate it and
um now we can't really get out of that
situation and perhaps what what the
effective accelerationists are afraid of
is that we will over regulate Ai and
then miss out on on on all of the
benefits and then there's there's some
theoretical justification thinking about
thermodynamics and evolution and the
kind of the the evolution not just
biologically but cosmically and um I
don't know about that but I I think
that's the that's the steel man for
their position
yeah thank you um for doing that I think
you did better than I probably could
have I think the
the cosmic Evolution notion
he's honestly kind of interesting to me
I find that to be like at least you know
philosophy worthy of consideration you
know how
Eliezer once said uh the in his way back
in his like FAQ and the meaning of life
the meaning of life is to create or
become our descendants
and
it thought that's you know pretty
interesting it's incredibly dense but it
can unpack in a lot of ways and you know
how different could those descendants be
from us
before I would feel like I don't care
about them anymore or that like that has
no value to me I think I'm honestly
probably a lot more open-minded than
most people in that respect I don't
think that's going to play with the
public super well but you know I'm uh
I'm willing to entertain some far out
ideas so that one is at least like
intriguing to me yeah we can think about
how our ancestors would be horrified by
a lot of the things that we consider to
be instances of moral progress today so
just you know the the equality of the
Sexes would probably be a difficult pill
to to swallow for someone in the in the
in the 15th century and and we might
evolve to to look at our you know our
descendants in the same way or we might
look at artists in a hypothetical
scenario we might look at our
descendants in the same way
yeah I think that's very that's very
plausible I mean a key question there
would seem to be like is there any
qualitative experience or you know
subjective sense of well-being that
these descendants have obviously that's
a
you know unanswered question at this
point that's another one I'm honestly
quite surprised where people
overwhelmingly seem to jump to the
conclusion that current systems are not
sentient or are not conscious or
whatever and I would reframe that
personally slightly to say I'm quite
sure they're not conscious like URI
architis that seems almost impossible
but
could there be anything that it feels
like to be gpt4
I have no way of ruling that out
personally I would it still feels kind
of unlikely but like I don't know where
my own subjective experience really
comes from and I was told as a kid that
animals didn't have subjective
experience and I took that at face value
for a Time
and now I'm like how could anyone have
ever thought that
so I you know you look at gpd4 you
interact with gbp4 you're like
on some level it seems like it has
something going on
why am I so confident that that there's
nothing that it feels like to be that I
don't know I would honestly be pleased
in some sense if we could
definitively show that gbg4 has some
feelings why would that be a good thing
yeah it would at least open up that
descendants you know that might be very
alien to us but like could have value if
they feel nothing it's hard for me to
get over that like I'm gonna have a real
hard time feeling like things are good
if nobody's home you know in the
universe so to speak all of this might
just be totally confused but if we could
say hey look somebody made up a
discovery that sort of has a unified
theory of Consciousness Consciousness
and look it applies to and we can
measure it maybe in some way or you know
put a number on it or something humans
have it at this level and here's what
dogs look like and here's what a
nematode looks like and here's what gbt4
looks like and it's like well a very
lopsided thing perhaps where it like
feels a lot of this kind of thing and
feels almost nothing like this but at
least something like that would be
interesting to me I think also it would
force us to confront a different set of
challenges around like what are we gonna
do with these things and you know how
fast should we deploy them and into
environments and just the more we can be
thoughtful about that probably the
better so I don't know I'm very
open-minded on all that stuff yeah I I
do think there's potentially something
suspicious about if you look at gpt2 and
then the evolution there and
capabilities to gpt4 there's obviously a
massive a massive jump but the
underlying kind of uh the underlying
technology is is pretty much the same
but we are I I'm guessing that people
would be more likely to describe some
form of proto-consciousness to gpt4 even
though what's going on under the hood
hasn't really changed it's been scaled
up and we've seen emerging capabilities
I worry that we might be in a world
pretty soon actually where we will be in
in a scenario like the movie her and
being able to talk to these models in in
natural language back and forth and it
will we will forget we will we won't we
won't think about anymore whether these
models are conscious simply because
they've been engineered and designed to
push all the right buttons for us so
that we feel of course these these
models are conscious I actually worry a
bit in the other direction that I agree
that we shouldn't we shouldn't uh
dogmatically rule out uh large language
model Consciousness but I I do worry
about kind of over ascribing
Consciousness too yeah totally you could
be wrong on both ends I mean that's kind
of the on all these things it seems like
you know you look back at
our whole conversation right it's like
all these major questions and it seems
like for almost all of these big
questions
you could be wrong on either end
of the spectrum and that's true I think
with the regulation the nuclear thing
too I'm not that sympathetic to that
argument in as much as I think it's very
true of nuclear like I wish we're
building more nuclear plants I look at
Germany's shutting down their nuclear
plants and I'm like what are you doing
guys like come on this is uh I just you
know so frustrated I can't wrap my head
around it so on that level I do
sympathize with you know at least the
the fear that like man there's such
promise here with this Ai and let's not
make that mistake I'm totally with that
but it's also like okay but you can be
wrong on both sides you know you could
over regulate and stifle and you know
foreclose on value prematurely but you
could definitely under regulate and end
up with you know who knows what
and in the end I think there is still I
mean you gave I think a best attempt at
an ex you know steel man but I think
that steel man still kind of relies on a
straw man which is the well you're just
gonna overregulated so much that it's
gonna be terrible and we're not gonna
miss out on all the value and well yeah
that could happen
but
I don't know how you look at the
situation and say you know we should
just
pump you know I mean the probably the
most operative question right now as far
as I know is should hyperscaling
continue
from where we are given what we know
I don't know how much compute was used
on gbt4 obviously it was a lot I think
Sam Altman has recently said it was
north of 100 million dollars worth of
spend it's obviously super capable it
doesn't seem like it's hit a wall you
know it seems like obviously you've got
this kind of long scale where it's not
going to be cheap you know to go another
10 to 100 x but if it was 100 million 10
100 x would only be 1 to 10 billion
Google makes a billion dollars a week in
profit
so that 10 billion is less than one
quarter worth of profit
for one company
so it's a lot but it's not that much I
have actually been a bit surprised about
how in a relative sense low these
numbers are so a hundred million dollars
for for companies of of the of Si such
as Google or Apple uh meta and so on
this is this is not a large amount of
money and I I imagine that uh a lot of
companies right now are racing towards
developing billion dollar models perhaps
uh 10 billion dollar models and you you
see this as The crucial question uh
should we
scale up as rapidly uh as we've done in
the past yeah I mean I could be
convinced that there's an even more
important question certainly
um I don't think this is the uh
you know the final view by any means but
yeah that's what that's kind of what I
came to coming out of the red teaming
you know in I wrote a report for openai
and the bottom lines
for me were
I think this technology is awesome I
think it is likely to be transformative
I think the good of gpt4 will
dramatically outweigh the bad there will
be a lot of bad but there will be even
way more good and I'm super excited
about it and you know I'm glad you guys
are doing a extended safety review But
ultimately I do endorse the deployment
however
it does not seem that we have a robust
way in fact it seems quite clear that we
do not have a robust way to predict let
alone control what would happen in
another 10 or 100x compute scale up
so I don't think we should do that right
now which isn't to say never you know
which kind of brings us back again to
this notion of a pause is the pause the
perfect thing I don't think that you
know even the you know sponsors of the
letter wouldn't necessarily think it was
the perfect thing it seemed to me like
it's you know somewhat of a consensus
and what what is like the you know the
thing we can agree on is probably more
of the binding constraint there than
anyone's notion of perfect
but
yeah I don't know I just you look at
these emerging capabilities that is the
thing that worries me most the
and the and to their credit
open AI has been quite forthcoming about
this
I think it is it is so easy I have my
concerns you know around how they're
approaching this and I do kind of think
you know hey and I was I thought it was
awesome that Sam Altman came out and
said yeah we're not doing gbt5 right now
I've heard some cynical takes on that as
well they're like they're just waiting
for Hardware to come in and you know
it's that's it was a convenient kind of
a low-cost thing for him to say but
nevertheless taking a face value I think
that that was very kind of encouraging
to me that they're not immediately
rushing to do the next one and I think
they've done a nice job of being
forthcoming like in the technical report
the graph for me that is the most
important graph
is the one where they show multiple
curves right they show the loss curve
and the case that they're kind of making
is we're getting very good at predicting
the loss curve you know we we made a
tiny little model with this architecture
and then 100 times bigger than that and
100 times bigger than that and 100 times
bigger than that and that was still only
one ten thousandth of gpt4 but when we
plotted that lost curve on this curve
and fit to it then boom it goes right
through the gpt4 point and therefore we
can predict loss sweet
problem there of course is
what's loss you know that's some general
measurement that Aggregates you know all
of these kind of next token predictions
and I think I think what something we
see there with the with the general loss
of these models is that in specific
domains you will see spikes so you will
see suddenly GPT style models are now
able to to accomplish some specific task
but if you generalize over all of the
models you see a more smooth loss curve
um is that a do you think that's right
yeah I mean and even in just the one you
know training process of gpt4
um so they try to I mean of course
they're smarter right so they understand
this and again they've been forthcoming
so then they show two
you know skills or like specific narrow
capabilities one of which was success on
a certain coding problem standard
and you know it's a little bit of a
bumpier curve but basically they're able
to fit you know the same curve and show
them again the tiny little model
couldn't do the problems and it got
better and you know more or less they're
able to predict what rate you know
what's what's the success rate the gbd4
is going to have on these coding
problems so cool you might think well
great now we can solve that we just
extrapolate that out we'll know how good
it's going to be oh but the next
sentence is some capabilities remain
hard to predict and then they show the
hindsight bias graph
where
basically they set up these little you
know toy problems where it's like you
had a decision to make you had certain
information available at the time you
made a reasonable decision but things
went against you maybe it was you know
you had a chance to make a bet where it
was a highly positive expected value you
did but you lost and then the question
is did you make the right decision
and it had previously been an example of
an inverse scaling law where the bigger
models seem to be getting worse on this
problem like there was something where
it was like understanding that the
outcome was the bad outcome and so
making the mistake that you know I
shouldn't have done that and that's
hindsight bias but the punch line is
when you get to gpt4
there is a spike to basically 100
correct
on the hindsight problem
and so I think of I mean I'm by no means
a Pioneer in this I don't know if you've
had Neil Nanda on the the show we have a
huge fan of his work uh and a huge fan
of the grocking you know exploration in
particular
it seems like
something like that happened for the
hindsight bias where you know a new
circuit kind of came online you know
there's a generalization from
a stochastic parent to be uh you know to
give
credit to the historical understanding
you know that that is what the small
models do but there seems to be some
shift some sort of phase change some
sort of moment of grocking where now you
know in the original gracking paper it's
modular Edition right and it goes from
it can only do the examples it seem to
it can do all the examples and at that
point it's pretty hard to say that that
model doesn't understand modular
division
I don't know what it would mean to
understand it if being able to do all
the problems like isn't you know in some
sense understanding then they reverse
engineer it and they get into like wow
it's doing this like Fourier transform
based like very weird Approach at least
from a human standpoint extremely weird
and yet it works and like it's not only
does it work but like you can look at
what it's doing and know that it's going
to work reliably that's amazing we can't
do that obviously with hindsight bias at
the scale of gpt4
but I'm guessing that something similar
is happening there
and
I just have no idea and I don't think
anybody else does and I think open AI
has been pretty straightforward about
the fact that they don't know
how many more of those grocking moments
happen on the next 10x or 100x of
compute
and you know they don't know when they
happen they don't know which ones happen
they don't know if there's like
extremely you know unpleasant surprises
that they await and you get back into
you know the sort of
a day of you know Holden Paul Cristiano
meme Plex of like
we're not fully reliable evaluators so
it seems pretty likely that at some
point it's gonna grok
that there's a difference between
objective reality and what satisfies you
know or elicits the highest feedback
score from the human
and I really don't want to see that
model come online uh in production until
we have a lot better understanding of
what's going on so it might happen it
might not happen in the next 10x but I
don't know I think we've got enough with
gpt4 like let's try to develop memes for
this one is AI servants not AI
scientists
like we have so much
benefit right in front of us let's you
know let's deploy it let's figure it out
let's integrate it into society we've
got enough to chew on
um in my mind before we go to
another you know however much scale up
of compute and like try to create you
know pasta
for if you know you know
yeah which which is in a sense kind of
at least in in in in in in some people's
opinion the Pinnacle of human
achievement the ability to discover new
knowledge and so on uh there's something
interesting about the fact that or yeah
I think if we were able to automate that
process we would have reached an end
state in which there would be nothing
else to automate this is the uh the
final thing that that we will hand over
to the AIS
um
the the question then Becomes of course
you're talking about the the problem of
when new uh capabilities arise in these
models and the the impossibility of
predicting this uh these new
capabilities this is what makes it the
case that you should probably never say
the sentence AIS will never be able to X
because you will be surprised by the
next model and this is also what what
potentially makes it so diff so so
dangerous if we we think about the
capability of situational awareness
arising in a model the capability the
new ways for models to be deceptive
around humans and so on so we've covered
a lot we've covered a lot of topics here
and and you said something interesting
about the the general uncertainty around
all of these topics I think if we are
doing podcasting on AI we are in a
domain in which we we will very quickly
be be proven wrong and our our whole
kind of uh conceptual schemes might be
might be mistaken because they are
either outdated or we have we have
created them so recently that that we
will have to adopt them so how do you
how do you think about how stable our
opinions should be in this domain I'm
very modest in my uh opinions you know I
try to put things out there
if I have reasonable confidence about
something that I think is you know
pretty likely to happen in the short
term I'll try to be concrete about it
because it feels like
you kind of have to in order to give
people something to grasp onto you know
if it's too hand wavy then yeah I think
people just don't know what to make of
it but I always try to contextualize
everything I'm saying with I'm pretty
confident we're going to see like AI
agents start to work in 2023 in such a
way where they can like do your online
grocery shopping
but I have no idea what happens in 2025
you know and uh and in the big picture
you know and how these agents play out
you know as they're all interacting with
each other what the what the Dynamics of
that are you know I have no idea so I I
try to kind of
Channel both like here's what I think
I'm confident on
and also
here's what I have radical uncertainty
on you know I try not to sugarcoat
anything for people because
I think it's done housing codes who says
I'm not here to give you hope or
whatever and that's kind of how I feel
too like I don't
I think I would be misleading or doing a
disservice to people if I sort of
reassured them that like whatever
happens it'll all be fine I don't think
that's obvious and you know in very
practical terms I try to spend half of
my time
just understanding what's going on you
know so I do have like a job at waymark
and I'm working with a couple other uh
companies as well I'm working with a
company called Athena which is in the
executive assistant space and trying to
help them figure out how do we like
become more productive and I love it
honestly it's so much fun to get
I really do love the technology getting
to me right down to the where the rubber
hits the road where people and AIS are
working together today I think is so
fascinating but even for them you know
I've said like I really don't know what
the big picture of this is and you know
it's definitely I can tell you we
definitely need to figure out how to
adopt these tools is that going to be
enough
long term I have no idea I really try
not to sugarcoat anything that I really
try to be as upfront as I can about the
radical uncertainty that it seems like
we are facing fantastic Nathan thank you
for coming on it's been super
interesting for me yeah this has been a
ton of fun great conversation thank you
very much